- Hi, this is Nicholas again.
Welcome back to the shop.
This is probably my most useful
tool in the shop.
I love my Chinese power hammer.
It's pneumatic,
it creates its own air,
and it works fantastic.
So this is
a Russian farmers anvil
that a friend gave me
a few years ago.
This is where most
of my knives get all
their finishing work done.
- Good morning.
My name is Dave,
and here we are at the forge.
This is my quench tank.
I made this
for the flamberge
rapier challenge.
I got my oxy-acetylene rig
here.
A portable all-purpose station.
Right now I have a grinder
in there.
I have my TIG welder,
my arc welder,
my band saw,
my little porta band.
I put a little bracket--a brace
on here so I could clamp it
to the table and use it like
a table saw.
In a small place like this,
many things have to do
double duty sometimes.
The hammer I like to use
the most is this one here.
I made this one.
It's a soft steel.
And it's got a nice rebound.
[taps, reverberates]
It's got a nice life to it.
That's it.
It's a humble little forge,
and this is where I create.
[rock music]
- So this is
my current armoring project.
It's a reproduction
of a 16th-century
pikeman's armor.
I have a long way to go.
There's lots of spikes.
I love making helmets.
This is a 16th-century...
dusty, Italian version a--
what they call the Heroic age.
So this is ode to the labors
of Hercules.
From the 16th century
we can go all the way
back to Roman.
This is
my Roman cavalry helmet.
It's a little dusty too.
This is all done
in a skill called
chasing and repoussé,
which means from the front
and from the back.
It's basically drawing
in steel, so it's a lot of fun.
It's one of the things
I really enjoy.
- A big part of being
a modern metal worker,
a blacksmith, a farrier,
an armorer is, you know,
you're wrestling with steel
all day long,
and my training in here
allows me to go out
and move steel.
[grunts]
And sometimes when I'm waiting,
let my body recuperate,
I'll throw a few darts.
You gotta show that.
That's pretty damn good.
Train, take care of yourselves,
and you can go out
and bang some steel.
Have a good day.